you're the knight I static book I move
around I judge in no man's land
there's danger of having to befriend the
group so are we me so my family choose
to bring me at the hospital we met off
med in a mental health hospital
Mogadishu
he kept crossing the front lines of
Somali civil war at night to visit his
friends It was as if you refused to
recognize the fractures in his hometown
Othman was our guide at the institution
based in a shell of a building we were
here to try and understand the full
weight of Somalia swore off I'd lived
through two decades of conflict that's
subsided in 2011 but the war wouldn't
end overnight battles continued outside
Mogadishu and all Shabaab launched
periodic attacks within the city the war
also continued on in people's memories
and hearts one third of people in
Somalia suffer from mental illness
according to the World Health
Organization okay oh yeah yeah what does
what does a Bab is a nurse trying to
reach them he is treating off med and
hundreds of others at the only mental
health institution in south-central
Somalia I'm sure he lost us afternoon
every week yesterday it's fantastic man
yes tomorrow
margin with little support and only
three months of psychiatry training he
has cobbled together his own way of
dealing with the war inside I'm Dino
Omari I stack Hey
Dada captain or memory I see vision my
name Hector Abdul Rahman Allen our
Magnum act ROM the mantle healthy
situation in Somalia is very very very
very serious every day three or four new
cases admitted from a parent brought me
here because of they'd show me they show
me that I was talking to myself I told
them every every human person they took
to ten surface in their heart but some
of them they speak Saturday but
according to me time was speaking us
locally that's why the my parents
brought him here
those were talking to themself is they
take drugs or take tablet is everyday
year begins with medication like a cup
hello in again I need to appreciate an
Indian man mr. Suraj AB AB told us how a
man he'd never met mr. Suri Raji sent
him fourteen thousand dollars to support
the clinic he says he used to receive
drugs from the World Health Organization
but he hasn't had their help for the
last two years
now he relies on individual donations
and small payments from the families of
patients mr. Shadley obtained go down
maja this is a social health and he's
increasing Kinky's to Allah
in Somalia mental illness is seldom
viewed as the disease more typically
it's seen as possession a Djinn or demon
can enter the body and occupy one's mind
to release a Djinn the afflicted person
visit sheiks who recite the Quran
sometimes they are starved so that the
jinn is also starved above bottles this
mindset every day
yes yes this is normal person that's a
message it's living together get it
together and talk to him and like kiss
is a person that is increasing
increasing increasing the and and
dignity of the mantle other people a
person
come on maybe dad ha ha okay
hey man's hands it up they sit down
together you confess their sin the tfcd
shouldn't say well do March it out over
the bus grandma Scotland
hey I'm Scott don't wash totally
colorful who washes don't life well
you're not waffling but not the other
industry there are worth ruining drunk
globalization after the waffle and
I know
now mentally oh people are often put in
Chains in Somalia and Habib has made it
his mission to end the practice Jenny no
able to move his hand not able to move
his leg seven years charity that young
people enjoy middle Sevilla now it's a
normal girls after tilted after game of
this yes
see we found in her bab a man fighting a
giant with imperfect tools and
unwavering conviction to be normal in
somalia is to have known trauma from
close up or in the background and so in
some ways it is the world outside these
walls that needs to catch up